simplify x to the third and then that
raised to the fourth power times x
squared and then that raised to the
fifth power now here we're going to use
the power property of exponents
sometimes called the power rule and that
just tells us if i have x to the a and
then i raise that to the b power this is
the same thing as x to the a times b
power and to see why that works let's
try that with a well i won't do it with
these right here i'll do it with a
simpler example let's say we are taking
x
squared and then raising that to the
third power well in that situation that
literally means multiplying x squared by
itself three times so that literally
means x squared
times x squared times x squared i'm
taking x squared and i'm raising it to
the third power now what does this mean
over here well there's a couple of ways
to do it you could just say like i have
the same base i'm taking the product i
can just add the exponent so this is
going to be this is going to be equal to
let me do that same magenta this is
equal to x to the 2 plus 2 plus 2 power
or essentially x to the three times two
this right here is just three times two
so we get x to the sixth power and if
you want you say hey sal well i don't
understand why you can add those
exponents you just have to remember that
x squared this thing right over here we
can rewrite as x times x
times x times x in parentheses i'm
putting each of these x squareds
times
x times x and this is just x times
itself 6 times x times x times x times x
times x times x this is just x to the
sixth power so that's why we can add the
exponents like that so let's just use
that power property on this expression
right over here we start off with we
have
x to the third raised to the fourth
power so that's just going to be x to
the three times four power or x to the
twelfth power
then
we're multiplying that by x squared
raised to the 5th power well that's just
going to be x to the 2 times 5 power or
x to the 10th power and now we have the
same base we can and we're taking the
product we can just add the exponents
this is going to be equal to
this whole expression is going to be
equal to x to the 12 plus 10th power or
x to the 22nd power and we are done